the return of the Stargate franchise is
happening and it's probably gonna be a
movie first but what will the cast be
and what can we expect from this new
franchise welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV a movie channel
[Music]
I've been giving you the news for 12
months now about all of the development
all of the rumors behind the scenes and
all of the stop starts while we've been
waiting for the Stargate franchise we
now know that it is about to be
announced and that actually it's San
Diego Comic-Con we're about to get the
finalized official announcements
but what is this thing about a probable
movie first well if you're a regular
site tracker you'll know that we
announced this a few months ago Amazon
are really pushing to do a movie first
but it's not definite just yet but if we
do get a movie will we be getting a
whole new cast will we be seeing a whole
new sg1 team or will there be some
regular faces in the mix
well what I'm hearing and what I've been
hearing for a few months now is that
actually Amazon don't want to spend a
fortune on the Stargate movie now I
suspect and this is just me speculating
but I suspect this is because
it's a bringing back a franchise to spin
off our screens for quite a long time is
a big risk doing a cinematic release
first is also a big risk if the
Cinematic release fails if it bombs and
loses a crapload of money you basically
kill the franchise before it even starts
but if you can do the movie on a
reasonable budget and it makes at least
a reasonable return it's an amazing
two-hour advert for the franchise and
the television series the follow-up
also there is a big thing at the moment
with sort of Legacy casts and bringing
back casts from all TV shows look at the
popularity of Picard season three that
really underlines for a lot of TV
Executives the people have an appetite
to see the old cast return
we've seen this in TV shows like
Criminal Minds Evolution
etc etc we're getting the old cast back
is very popular with TV viewers so would
Stargate return with the faces we
recognize well according to the sources
that we speak to over at Sidetrack
Amanda Tapping and Michael Shanks to
play General Carter and Daniel Jackson
have already been approached that them
returning is almost definite it would
not surprise me in the slightest if it's
San Diego Comic-Con we suddenly find out
that Amanda Tapping and Michael Shanks
are on a panel and then that panel will
then be used to actually release the
official announcement of the Stargate
movie television series whatever
now it would seem that we are going to
see General Carter and Daniel Jackson in
that movie but could we see The Return
of several other actors well we've also
talked about this channel how actually
an SGU story has been considered and
actors like David blue and Robert
Carlisle have potentially already been
very unofficially sounded out about a
return however I can't see SGU being at
the Forefront of the initial return of
Stargate I think that requires too much
knowledge of the previous franchise I
think they are going to have to go with
a movie that can draw in new viewers so
I think they will probably put SG onto
the back burner at least initially but I
can tell you now that again Amazon have
approached these actors which would
suggest that actually resolving the SGU
mystery is a priority and will happen
relatively early in the franchise
act as though I could see 100 returning
are actors from Stargate Atlantis and
Stargate sg1 I would be amazed if we
didn't see Christopher Judge as teal
return indeed
actors like Ben Browder and Claudia
Black returning would again be amazing
look I want to see Vala with Daniel so
if they don't return with Claudia Black
I'd be absolutely shocked the one actor
I would adore see return is David
Hewlett McKay was always one of my
favorite actors when he went into
Atlantis I was so pleased because you
know we'd loved him in sgy him bouncing
around with Samantha Carter was just
hilarious and then when they moved him
into Atlantis his relationship with
Shepard and Ronan was just some of the
best moments of that Series so if David
Hewlett doesn't return they again are
really missing out on an obvious and
simple home run to make the Gators very
very happy talking about Atlantis though
Joe Flanagan he is a huge Stargate fan
he adores the franchise he would very
very happily return he he tried to buy
it for God like so get in Colonel
Shepherd's return or maybe no General
Shepherd could we get to see a couple of
the actors from sort of the periphery of
Stargate Atlantis that came in towards
the end dual status Keller again
I I it would make sci-fi fans very very
happy as well one of our favorite
characters from Firefly we adored her
when she came into Stargate Atlantis
bring back Keller all day long
but Robert picardo was Woolsey
he is one of those just brilliant
character actors that can carry a scene
all on his own again he would be very
easy to slip into something with the
Stargate movie and the follow-on series
is one of those characters that allows
you to bring other characters in to
certain situations and really could be
Central to any new plot very very easily
a lot of people are not big fans of Ben
Browder and Colonel Mitchell but to be
honest I always thought he was great a
lot of the actors I've mentioned
Christopher George Ben Browder Michael
Shanks etc etc are still effective
working actors they have not aged
terribly badly Ben Browder was in the
release center and Guardians of the
Galaxy movie all painted up in gold and
I'm certain he can still believably
carry out an action role it's not to be
honest like Harrison Ford in the new
Indiana Jones movie geriatric Indie
where you do wonder how is he running
how is he even standing Wednesday's in
my friend it's not like that these
actors are not that ancient they can
still carry off a big role now I would
love to see The Return of many of these
actors Blended in with new actors I'm
not one of these people that go ah
you've got to bring the old cast back or
just doesn't work I I don't believe that
people yelled at the Next Generation
basically when that returned if you get
the right actors in the right roles it
doesn't matter if they're new it doesn't
matter if they're young or old or black
or yellow or white or pink or pink polka
starts it doesn't matter if you get the
right actors for the right role
and I'd love to see obviously a lot of
the familiar faces returned but I also
want to see a blend of new actors new
characters for us to meet and I really
think that story Amazon will go with
this but there is one name you'll notice
I haven't mentioned Richard Dean
Anderson he's been doing a lot of Comic
Cons in the last few years and the man
is looking good now he did put a fair
bit of weight on a couple of years ago I
won't lie there is actually rumor that a
couple of years ago when Brad Wright had
the script to do for MGM and it looked
like he was going to get to do his
Stargate that actually he told Richard
Dean Anderson dude you got to hit the
gym you got to lose some weight because
you're coming back and he would have
come back for that script now he did hit
the gym he has lost a crapload away and
he looks a damn sight better for I was
actually quite worried about his health
a couple of years ago he is looking like
Richard Dean Anderson again I've seen
him in loads of Comic Cons sat next to
Amanda Tapping I do wonder if he might
make a surprise appearance at San Diego
Comic-Con 2023 because that would be
very cool
I'm really hoping that we see Michael
Shanks Amanda Tapping sat down in the
chair answering a few questions and then
smoke excitement RDA walks on and then
we know that we've got something really
exciting planned now we actually talked
about an idea that Bad Robot had for
Richard Dean Anderson in the Stargate
return that they pitched at the Stargate
movie about nine months ago their plan
was to bring Richard Dean Anderson back
but they were going to kill General
O'Neill two Wells as part of that movie
now I've always loved the idea that we
would get to see Richard Dean Anderson
come back for a film but then we would
get to say goodbye to the character in a
big way I think that would be exciting
him having to sacrifice himself to save
the universe basically
can't see Richard Dean Lansing returning
for any major role in a movie or TV
series but let's be honest Amazon get a
dumper truck full of money drive it to
Richard Dean Anson's house and basically
say take what you want
we want you for the movie just take
anything you want
that is what we want for a Stargate
reboot but guys against the comments
tell me what you think who are the
actors you want to see return who are
the actors you don't I'd love to know
exactly what you're thinking get into
the comments who were your favorite
actors from the three Stargate franchise
shows and who are the ones that you
don't want to see return
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you will never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com forward slash
Sidetrack where you get to see most of
our videos first and for a small
contribution each month you get to see
them without the adverts
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]